[Music]
when I was thinking about what exactly a
sequel to doom 2016 needed I thought of
the obvious more demons more guns and
cool new environments what I didn't
think about was mobility which in
retrospect was an obvious direction to
go in it doesn't get brought up much
when talking about it but doom 2016 had
a lot of platforming in it it was
primarily used to break up the pacing
and give a breather from combat
eventually it would become part of the
combat as well feeding into the game's
design of always needing to be on the
move in order to stay alive rather than
simply taking cover
but people praised doom for its combats
bloody visuals and head-banging
soundtrack not the platforming it got
the job done but it didn't feel
invigorating the way the rest of the
game did but doom eternal looks to fix
all that by making platforming and
mobility a core part of the experience I
think we wanted to make sure that the
incidental combat areas which is the
spaces in between the large combat
arenas would would be more interesting
you start to take those abilities and
combine them together what you get is
what we call traversal combos and and
you're gonna be able to do some really
cool things you can cover a lot of
ground with the monkey bar swing and
double jumping in two dashes and a
grapple hook and then you had wall climb
into that and I think it's gonna make
for some really interesting traversals
and it has an impact on the way the
levels are designed they're designed
maybe not so two-dimensional and flat
now we could do a lot more different
things that we couldn't do before we've
provided ourselves with the tools to be
able to make some really compelling
spaces simple additions like climbing
and air dashes open up the potential for
more interesting exploration and could
greatly improve the creativity required
to locate hidden secrets but the most
meaningful addition is what the game
refers to as the meathook a grappling
hook attached to the super shotgun that
pulls you towards demons this feeds
perfectly into dooms combat which is all
about killing demons as fast as possible
and that meathook is a great way to get
those deep
and your bullets to meet each other but
also has the potential to drastically
change the dynamics of combat and open
up new styles of play with aerial combos
it feels good to try to stay in the air
as long as you can and we give you a
bunch of these things to allow you to do
that absolutely that's the mini game it
happens it's just intuitive like you
feel like you want to do it so we
provide you with the chance to do it in
that yeah in fact in that second that
second kind of gameplay video that we
said we were gonna kind of make go you
know faster is keyboard and mouse non
cast off that player he's one of our
better players in the office Sean place
so so well because you can only you can
only grab but you can only meathook to
demons it's not a like a world grapple
like you can't grapple onto the side of
the building so you have to grapple to a
demon so he leaves a demon kind of
flying around so that he can use it as a
grapple point to get kind of wherever he
wants in the in this space so yeah I
mean it creates just more opportunities
more things to think about as you're as
you're playing the game more more
opportunities to kind of improv your way
through through the through the fight
choreography what we saw QuakeCon is
only a small taste of the game and I'm
curious to see what new enemies and
interesting levels can be built around
these new mechanics while doom eternal
doesn't have the shock of surprise the
previous doom had when people first
played it I'm glad to see the devs that
are pushing the follow-up game further
with new ideas hopefully it won't be too
long before we get a chance to play it
ourselves
[Music]